hi guys it's silver ed again and this is
kind of a different video than usual
because I want to rant about something
that you've maybe heard of by now so a
while ago Atari posted a tweet about the
possible release of ICT for M so of
course the fans went apeshit over what
the M would mean ICT for men ICT for
multiplayer I would download buy 20
copies of a permit that were true by the
way ICT for marijuana but no all of that
didn't happen of course it turned out to
be RCT for mobile rct3 came out in 2004
and for 10 years all the fans have been
debating what ICT for would have been
like possibilities would be endless and
it would show surpass anything else and
go beyond what the simulation game genre
has ever offered I mean look at this
ICT one was great but looking kind of
shitty and ICT 2 looks a bit better but
I 63 was all like 3d and awesome and oh
my god you can write the rollercoasters
so we all thought that rolling screen 4
would be something so good Atari win a
damn Nobel Prize for the floors game
playing graphics and I was damn well
looking forward to the possible release
of ICT 4 but Oteri's like nope
we'll just make it give me your money
otherwise this game on be a terrible
experience farmville ripoff with
circular wooden loops brilliant of
course this concepts have been very
popular with the fans not look at this
like dislike ratio it's not even that
bad on Friday or even baby
smart move Atari I don't understand how
Atari directors could be sitting at a
table brainstorming about what to do
when one dumbass stands up and says hey
I have an idea let's make our city for
mobile and they all go
kay it's either that or a bunch of evil
maniacs plotting the next move against
our poor community with evil laughter
and everything it really seems like that
just trying to milk a good franchise
because by now Atari is pretty much that
drunk homeless person who used to be a
superstar of the gaming industry and it
really seems like this is a pathetic try
to get your money so needless to say I'm
probably not going to play this heck I'd
rather have ICT 1 for Android than this
poor excuse for entertainment I'm going
to stick with ICT three and probably
theme parks to do and try to get over
this major disappointment I'm out of
here